j'accueille maintenant gaspard proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
oui et oui et je suis content je suis
content de te voir ces mois ci si tu es
là c'est que tu as retrouvé du boulot
non mais c'est vrai fin mai il y est il
est là pour une pièce de théâtre ah
ouais donc enfants qui s'attend non
c'est pas encore ça non mais faut être
lucide le théâtre c'est quoi ces îles
foyer emmaüs du cinéma quoi si
c'est vrai c'est le la spa des
producteurs parfois ils adoptent et puis
faut un deux trois films 4 puis après on
voit l'acteur attaché bord de
l'autoroute des vacances comme ça enfin
dans le jargon ça s'appelle un téléfilm
sur tf1
enfin bref la semaine alors cette
semaine nous avons été à 11 septembre
c'est une date très très importante
l'anniversaire de bachar al assad oui et
on comprend mieux certaines choses il
est vierge a alors maintenant sachant
que sa femme est née le 11 août la seule
vraie question qui se pose c'est quoi
est-ce que ça peut durer entre un vierge
et union
cette combinaison peut fonctionner très
bien le lion peut offrir l'imagination
et l'excitation alors que la vierge peut
offrir son esprit une analyse son sens
de l'ordre un jeune
c'est et nous on veut briser ce couple
[Applaudissements]
mai
quand qu'on les laisse ses mais
de tout ça tout ça parce que hollande il
prend la guerre en syrie pour un jeu
vidéo d'arcade à trois niveaux tu sais
le niveau simple c'est le mali tu sautes
sur les dromadaires du manioc en syrie
tu rajoutes le paysage urbain puis
troisième niveau très difficile ac
marseille tu attrapes un guetteur de rue
parce que
je me disais à propos de bachar qu'on
voulait punir détruire supprimer
vraiment à la schlague quoi dire bachar
par rapport à la réforme taubira c'est
quand même bizarre de vouloir mettre en
place des peines de probation pour des
délinquants reconnu coupable en france
et en même temps envisagée la peine de
mort pour des suspects présumés
innocents à l'étranger
[Applaudissements]
le sport évidemment le pense est
important de parler aussi un peu d'eux
pelouse il ya il ya un malaise benzema
dans l'équipe de france arrêtons de
l'accabler et le mec gagne 8,5 millions
d'euros par an au real équipe de france
tu touches 15000 euros par match à ce
tarif il est gentil de toucher la balle
non mais benzema en équipe de france et
c'est alain ducasse qui vient faire une
pige au mcdo quoi
après l'équipe de france n'est pas
toujours irréprochable dans ses demandes
danser comme planes surtout c'est elle
se plaint d'être mal aimés c'est sûr que
c'est pas en allant aux [ __ ] que tu te
fais une idée complète de l'amour
le bon coin ah oui aux etats unis des
couples revente des enfants qu'ils ont
adoptée et les revendre sur internet
alors jusque là pourquoi pas mais en
revanche les argumentaires de vente suis
tombé sur une annonce je cite j'ai honte
de le dire mais nous détestons vraiment
cet enfant
c'est quand même malheureux devant ton
gosse comme ça je veux dire si tu vends
une voiture tudip avant voitures
pourries qui n'a été qu'une source dans
merde
alors forcément je me suis retiré des
enchères jeu par
éducation peillon vincent a sorti sa
charte sur la laïcité ça ne va servir à
gré il faut que les gens puissent
s'identifier laïcité laïcité personne
connaît la cité des 4000 des tarterets
mais laïcité
leur pays on veut refondre les
programmes ça c'est la marotte des
nouveaux ministres d'aidé qu'ils
arrivent quand tu arrives à l'éducation
nationale turf et les programmes de
l'éducation nationale c'est le seul
endroit où les mises à jour rendre le
système moins performants kaua safari
un éléphant a tué un vieillard avec sa
trompe en seine-et-marne c'est pas
étonnant en ce moment de ces les
éléphants il quitte les hauts plateaux
de picardie pour aller rejoindre le
bassin francilien faut vraiment
respecter l'équilibré fragile de cette
région c'est un écosystème d'une beauté
absolue
spectacle extraordinaire bon récemment
je suis allé en baie de saint malo voir
l'accouplement des crocodiles
c'était sublime c'est quand tu vois le
crocodile affalé comme ça etc à
l'improviste un ours polaire qui passe
il ya une
sport toujours kevin lefaix jusque là ça
ne dit rien à personne c'est normal
c'est un attaquant du red star qui
souffre d'une fracture du nez alors
c'est un petit jeune qui monte juste
envie de dire la coke c'est avec une
paille pas avec un marteau
cinéma
la rentrée dans la de l'ong qui a
déclaré que l'homosexualité était contre
nature dire ça au xxième siècle faire
l'apologie de l'hétérosexualité
pour alain delon l'homosexualité contre
nature il a fait rocco et ses frères
non mais je dire comment est ce qu'on
peut encourager les l'hétérosexualité
quand on sait que statistiquement
monsieur ciotti vous ne dites jamais
tous les délinquants je dis bien tous
les délinquants sont les enfants d'un
couple hétéro
en débat on vous l'a jamais fait ça là
encore
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est ces faits drass c'est
grave mais que c'est pierre bergé oui
économie alors la police vient de
démanteler le plus grand camp de roms à
lille ouais en fait les flics qui ne
sont plus en concurrence avec la
gendarmerie mais avec des mes côtés
s'est devient les tipis savent plus
arrêter un coupable en revanche ils
savent parfaitement comment on fait
bouger une caravane une armoire normande
c'est
alors les robes fallait un endroit très
simple pour les reloger c'est toujours
un problème il pourrait faire partie de
l'expo permanente du salon de la
caravane porte de versailles à paris
voilà alors
mémoire à l'allemagne va renvoyer devant
la justice les gardes du camp
d'auschwitz
à l'époque les mecs il avait 21 ans
enfin faut se remettre dans le contexte
en 40 en allemagne gardien de caen stern
emplois d'avenir
amour de vue ont été retrouvés ligotés
dans une maison voilà ce qui arrive
quand on joue des jeux sm et qu'à cause
d'alzheimer on a oublié le mot de passe
pour dire stop
[Applaudissements]
alors bonne nouvelle de la semaine à un
bijoutier touche un braqueur je tiens à
rassurer tout le monde le scooter marche
toujours alors pas belle la vie
jojo
là demain à 15 heures en france
gallet et bien sûr sur canalplus.fr et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu